what does a Vulcan sibling relationship
mean to you and then to Spock oh my
goodness well you will find out what our
sibling relationship means it's very
complicated but we do find out pretty
quickly what the sort of crux of it all
is and it's quite raw but it's necessary
and I think that it's a very compelling
relationship because it is so
complicated I hope that she can be as
complex and flawed as she is and admit
her mistakes and try and ramify them and
have some more self-worth because I feel
like she is a reaction to the culture
that she's a part of behaves the way she
does because that's how she's been told
the only way she can function is house
Makai spies like all that sort of stuff
so I hope that that evolution can be
empowered hikin Burnham early on in the
second season forge an agreement that
we're gonna trust each other because he
recognizes the talent very quickly like
that's a captain in the making there's
no question he would probably never tell
her that but he really relies upon her
for more than just betting his ideas she
has an incredibly strong moral core as
does Martha brain and you know I've I as
an actor relied upon cinema to help me
get into this world so it's a great
parallel relationship there she's earned
earned his trust the relationship the
brother-sister like the locking horns we
did all through season one but the the
competitive annoyances that we you that
we found in each other we've overcome
that now and this is it's a very emotive
there are emotional beats that I didn't
even see coming Alex always wanted to
shoot anamorphic because he loves how
big the frame is and you
much intimacy with the characters so
that was a conscious choice I don't know
if necessarily people watch the first
episode and think it's bigger than the
pilot but we'll see how does Tyler
respond to all of this is he fully
supportive or is there any kind I think
easy soldiers easy now it's his duty you
know say he we were saying is sort of
like the command training program
everything until he wanted it to be so
good and it's so scary and it's
wonderful she's exactly where she wants
to be and she's very grateful to servo
for making that happen in one of the
trailers we hear a pike mentioned that
he likes to keep fun in the equation
here so can you explain how exactly he's
going to infuse Discovery with that
sense of fun I think that Pike just in
general is not afraid of being
self-deprecating and I think it's one of
his strengths as a captain he's not
afraid to admit I have no idea what's
happening right now and to say anybody
got a better idea and best idea wins
that's how he runs his ship and it's
it's smart it's he because he's
expanding his brain to the entire bridge
and it makes for really fun see the
whole season is gonna be a little more
fun and I think as much as we loved last
season which we did and we're all
incredibly proud of it it was the season
where we were at war even though we were
able to have lighter episodes and some
lighter characters you still have that
hanging over your head
so it was a conscious decision this
season as a whole to make it a little
lighter
there is levity because the war is over
now that doesn't mean that everything is
easy and doors don't no that's not what
it means we we have a lot of work to do
still but the fun will see what's fun
Burnham
it kind of takes a lot
[Music]